please i urge you stop do not go any
further this
is gonna be a gruesome video if you have
not seen the final destination series
before
we're gonna be watching and reacting to
some of the most gruesome injuries
from the five movies i'm scared you
should be scared by the way this is
merch let's just do it let's get started
[Music]
is he gonna die of um drowning because
he's stuck in hell to this thing
oh my god no this is not
what's about to happen tell me my guy is
going to get sucked into that or his
organs are going to get sucked into that
oh my god this is not real i need an
engineer to tell me but where's dr
espino when you need him i really feel
like pool's just drained by gravity but
even if there is like a little sucking
mechanism it's mild it's like
not like rip up your inside shoot them
outside of the suction device
let's go get in the car i've got my eye
on
youtube oh i feel like that's an eye
reference
i can't could that happen i mean maybe
wow wow i mean like that's the softest
part to get into the
the skull for sure
i just win that's all i know i do kevin
baby i just win
oh he had to go for the extra rep
i know you're probably expecting for me
to give you the medical reasoning as to
why
his life is no longer continuing
he once had a head
and then he didn't
oh why was there a random bolt
ow
oh i was not expecting that
oh my god why did she let go i know the
stuff went in her eyes
but if she just held on or slowed down
or something there's like a safe way to
dismount
she went for the tricks and stuff that
was unnecessary that's
that's like a c6 c7
cervical fracture paralysis potentially
death
wow who wants to be the first to tell me
what the hell just happened
who is it sam it was what
oh my god reminds me of that dodgeball
seat you can dodge a wrench
you can dodge a ball what
i was always taught that if you're in a
car that's getting electrocuted either
by lightning
or some other source you'd be safe
because of the rubber tires
whoa
alexa alex alex
[__] really hold on alex come on
stay with me look at that good chest
compressions
and final destination a little chest
compressions chest compressions chest
compress
i wish i was wearing that merch instead
of this one oh my god that's so good
oh my god that looks like the scene when
i run with the pigeons run with me
my god i did not expect a pigeon-related
death this
early into the series that's that's not
that's like a
decapitation crush compression fracture
incompatible with life type situation
i'm moving on
carter and if you want to waste your
life
beating the [__] out of alex every time
you see him
then you can just i remember she's
getting hit by a bus oh
i mean what am i gonna say medically
there that's a level one trauma right
there
i don't know why buses are speeding at
70 miles an hour
on pedestrian line streets they don't
break for humans like
was this a runaway bus like
so many questions you're dead you're
dead
and you're attacking me window
oh that's a decapitation obviously
you're gonna have some blood
coming out and squirting from the
carotid arteries maybe even the
vertebral artery in the back of the
spine this is like usually regarded as a
painless death if it's done swiftly
because within a matter of a few seconds
you become unconscious
and your brain can't feel pain doing eeg
trials where we actually look at brain
activity brain waves
it seems like it's only a few seconds
that you can experience any kind of
discomfort and then the reality is you
start experiencing brain death quite
soon simply because of hypoxia you're
not getting enough oxygenation to the
brain because you have no blood flow to
the brain
i'm not gonna die it's you wendy you're
dead
if i was to tell anything to final
destination actors
would be to not get overconfident with
death because it seems like any time
someone says i'm good
they're not oh this is the second time
i'm gonna explain that
when you have a human body
and a heavy object falls on them and
there's no more human body
in compatibility with life
these tremors that you're seeing they
can even happen with decapitation where
there's still some residual electric
activity in the brain in the muscles
in the nerves causing these types of
movements they are not
controlled by your conscious thought
this is a result of
pre-existing synapses that are still
firing do not
think of that as still the person
feeling the pain
if an object of that size or magnitude
falls on you you're not feeling anything
[Music]
oh
first of all what kind of fishing line
is he using as a close
line hanger that looks like it's
borderline floss
like that looks painful
that's a that's a really quick death
there not only because
of the area obviously that's being
compressed where you have the carotid
arteries they're supplying blood flow to
the brain they're being closed off so
you're not getting circulation so you
pass out really quickly the real danger
comes from the fact that the
clothesline that is choking him right
now is really thin so eventually it's
gonna start cutting into his skin from
the weight of the body whenever you have
less surface area on anything putting
pressure against your skin
it's more likely to make an incision
into it and cut through it's like one of
the worst deaths
i remember this oh no
oh oh oh no
oh no again why does no one use the
brakes in these movies
they're accelerating into the other cars
having a giant
piece of lumber go through your head is
not compatible with life um
being on a motorcycle falling off of it
and then having that motorcycle
cut your body in half is not compatible
with life
again why isn't she pressing the brake
oh that's the worst okay obviously
explosion also not
compatible with life but the water
bottle thing i take that so seriously
like you have no idea i see my friends
sip on a water bottle and they put it
next to them or they put in between
their legs i freak out so
please make sure the area around your
pedals is clear foreign objects
[Applause]
again survivable role there survivable
role when we're talking about
bad car accidents the worst ones are
where you come to an immediate stop
because of inertia and momentum your
organs actually keep moving while your
car stops your body stops and the car
tries to absorb some of that impact
that's why car frames are actually made
in a way where they're collapsible a lot
of people think it needs to have this
really strong frame that never breaks
but the reality is you wanted to have
give you wanted to almost act like an
accordion and collapse around you and
then keep you safe in that shell the bit
the worse accidents as i was saying are
the ones where you come
like from a 60 mile an hour to a zero
mile an hour collision those are very
deadly the ones where you're rolling and
momentum kind of keeps you forward
obviously there's danger there and you
could hurt yourself hitting your head
but if you're wearing your seatbelt and
you have the airbag on those are the
more survivable
ones
some of these people on this airplane
sound like dinosaurs i don't know
they're like
this is no lie one of my biggest fears
by the way
oh no
i love that they're reaching for each
other i mean like i understand the human
nature to want to do that
the plane is about to crash i don't even
know who has a better chance of
surviving
the person that's jumping out of the
plane right now and landing in the water
or the plane actually crashing into the
water
unless they get sucked into the engine
then that's kind of a loss-loss type
situation
you know not gonna lie if there's a way
to go during a plane crash
it's getting hit in the head with a
piece of luggage and being knocked
unconscious and then just enjoying the
ride down well not enjoying it but
at least not being deathly afraid
[Music]
i hate roller coasters for so many
reasons i'm so scared of them
oh no worse fears coming to fruition
why did the seatbelt belts fail like
what is happening
oh no everything's just falling apart
oh my god the ironic thing this roller
coaster is probably called like the ring
of death
and the reality is it's become the ring
[Music]
where's the roller coaster ride operated
oh my god
that's why they say keep all your hands
and limbs inside
for the rides to prevent that from
happening
to decompress and have a laugh click
here for my nine gag medical meme review
video
it's absolutely certain to make you
laugh have a good time and learn
something in the process as always stay
happy
and healthy